all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are back with dark crisis on
infinite Earth but before we get back
into the main story we're covering this
big bang one shot which is basically DC
Comics in effect rebooting the form and
function of their entire Multiverse
they're changing seemingly everything
which is why I've always been saying
dark crisis on infinite Earth even
though DC is not billing it as a reboot
it feels like a reboot so here's the way
this works and the first thing we need
to really talk about here is the nature
of Wally West so as you guys will notice
you have Barry Allen and then you have
the newer version of Wally West so for
those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with this the way this worked is that in
DC Comics you had the original
red-haired Wally West he was the first
kid flash when Barry Allen died during
the events of crisis on infinite Earth
which we'll talk about here in a second
that that version of Wally the old
school version became the new main Flash
and he operated that way until the
events of final crisis now as we've
talked about with crisis events crisis
on infinite Earth destroyed the
Multiverse Infinite Crisis brought it
back and then final crisis made the
heroes aware of the multiverse's return
and so when Barry Allen came back that
what you had was Barry Allen and the
original Wally West who were running
around as kind of the one-two punch of
The Flash family when DC rebooted in
2011 with the new 52 they got rid of the
original Wally West and they replaced
him with the version that you see here
now as you would expect when it comes to
the removal of a character and their
replacement with a newer character some
people loved it some people hated it the
important thing here though is that
because New 52 in general was not overly
well received that what DC did is they
launched rebirth in 2015 and 2016 and
that basically led to the return of the
original Wally West so as it stands now
you've got two Wally's running around
now to be honest with you guys I think a
time will come when they will kill off
this younger version of Wally and
they'll basically replace him with the
original Wally since that really seems
to be the one that fans love the most
but we'll see what happens right I have
no idea if that's actually going to take
place the important thing here is is
that the younger Wally is inexperienced
with the Multiverse he doesn't know how
it works and so he asked Barry Allen to
basically explain it to him now here's
the funny thing Barry literally says
this is the map of the Multiverse and
he's basically been charting it that
dozens of parallel Earths and parallel
universes all vibrate at a unique
frequency it's expansive but it's always
been finite and he says until now the
cosmic limitation on their number has
been lifted and we're rediscovering an
infinite number of earths now here's the
reason why that matters right going back
to our example of crisis on infinite
Earth's destroying the Multiverse
Infinite Crisis bringing it back and
final crisis making the heroes aware of
it that where you had the heroes
becoming aware of the multiverses return
you had a guy named Grant Morrison who
wrote final crisis but also wrote a
story called multiversity and
multiversity was basically a guidebook
that existed in two parts that said
here's what the Multiverse looks like
right here are the different worlds that
are part of the Multiverse but it was
kind of an unofficial rule in DC Comics
that it was always 52 right it was kind
of alluded that there were an infinite
number of Worlds out there but DC played
it on both ways right they were kind of
like I mean you know there might be an
infinite number of universes we don't
really know but like here's 52. what DC
is doing here is they're saying there is
an infinite number of universes out
there they're they're seemingly never
was before right the way it worked
before is there were only ever 52 worlds
in the Multiverse and that was it now
there's an infinite number of them how
long it will stay that way is anybody's
guess but the person that Barry Allen is
hunting for is basically the
anti-monitor and this is where he
explains that bit to the newer Wally and
saying that during the events of crisis
on infinite Earth when the anti-monitor
was initially Unleashed on the
Multiverse that the anti-monitor used
Barry Allen as a kind of battery in
order to power a device that would allow
him to wipe out what was left of the
Multiverse which is to say the world the
anti-monitor hadn't destroyed and one
Fell Swoop and what that would do is it
would wipe out everything in existence
and the anti-monitor could recreate the
Multiverse as an antimatter Multiverse
and he himself would be the god of it
right he would rule everything
ultimately of course he was defeated but
when Barry Allen was believed to have
been killed during the events of
Christ's son infinite Earth the way the
story was originally told he was dead
right he was dead as a doornail and he
was never going to come back right that
was literally it you went from Christ on
infinite Earth into like Mike Barron's
flash which focused on Wally then into
Mark wage run which is kind of the
seminal run right probably the most
important and iconic run of the flash
terminal velocity different stories like
that Grant Morrison had a little bit of
a writing stint in it but the thing
about this is that it all focused on
Wally there was no indication Barry
Allen was ever going to return the only
real indication that we got of Barry
Allen returning was this idea that he
appeared to Wally basically from the
past traveling to the Future to that
present and saying like I'm gonna help
you a few times but then I'm going to go
back to my time and like that's gonna be
it that's all we really got in terms of
very Alan potentially returning when he
reappeared in Final crisis that blew
everybody away and so what DC did is
they came back and they said okay so
Barry Allen was never killed during the
events of crisis on infinite Earth you
think he was because we basically told
you he was but he wasn't like instead he
was just trapped in the speed force and
he's been there ever since and so he
ultimately escaped the speed force and
then he returned as Barry Allen and so
that's kind of the funny thing here
about how DC works this stuff but the
reality is in an effort to find the
anti-monitor what Barry Allen and what
Wally do is they travel the Multiverse
of course they pick up with Earth 23
they pick up with Earth 118 which is the
home to the Dark Knights of Steel which
by the way I know a lot of you guys have
been asking when are we going to finish
the Dark Knights of Steel here's the
problem DC releases one issue in April
and the next issue doesn't come out
until November it's inconsistent as hell
a lot of that's because Tom Taylor was
the one who was riding Dark Knights of
Steel and then he stopped writing it so
he could basically finish deceased which
we need to cover but the thing about
this is that it gets released whenever
it gets released sometimes it's like a
year between issues that's why it's been
so long since we covered it because it's
been so long since an issue came out so
just be aware I'm waiting until we get
more releases to be able to cover them
but just to make sure you guys know
what's going on but traveling through
the Multiverse they travel through Earth
22 right basically the world of kingdom
come for the most part these are
universes that we're aware of but he
ends up traveling to earth 28. now Earth
28 was basically a world where you had
these different superheroes that were
replaced with robots it's somewhat
reminiscent of DC's Futures End right
the story that we shall not that we
shall not acknowledge everybody hates
that story because it was a terrible
story it is not the Futures and the
universe but it kind of feels similar to
it it's almost like DC meets
Transformers is really what it is but
the thing about this is the anti-monitor
is basically laying waste to everybody
now Wally not really understanding what
he's messing with gets too close to the
anti-monitor and is seized by the
anti-modern now one of the first things
Barry told Wally when while he asked him
can you defeat the anti-monitor the
responsiberry was hell no oh there's no
way I could beat this guy on my own not
a chance but we'll have to find some
kind of of backup in order to make that
happen he says in his true form the
anti-monitor can never really be
defeated right he's composed of
antimatter energy and so he's kind of a
Yen to the positive matter universes
Yang he has to exist the best we can do
is send him back to his anti-matter
universe but that's really it right he
cannot he can never really truly be
destroyed and so because while he's
captured Barry Allen does something that
honestly I'm not entirely sure I'm a fan
of right he literally just starts
traveling around the world as fast as he
possibly can and what he says is the
faster a body moves the more its mass
increases now those of you guys who are
familiar with the flash you know exactly
what's coming here and it is a cool
moment don't get me wrong it's a cool
moment but I don't know how I feel about
Barry doing it right like Barry's just
traveling around as fast as humanly
possible he builds up his Mass to a near
infinite level and then takes all that
mass in the form of a punch and punches
the anti-monitor through the Multiverse
by using the infinite Mass punch now
here's the thing the reason why I'm not
sure about how I feel with Barry Allen
doing it is because that's Wally West's
thing right like Wally West had the
infinite Mass punch that was his move
right it was it was his thing you know
like it was it was just you can't take
that away from him man it's like one of
the things that made him unique Granite
Barry Allen's done it before and
technically within the comics Wally's
the one that taught Barry how to do it
but the reality here is like that should
be Wally's thing it makes him unique
right it's one of the things that makes
him just a character that's different
from all the other flashes so I'm kind
of curious what your all's thoughts are
right like do you guys like the idea of
very using the infinite Mass Punch or do
you think that should stay Wally's thing
but the thing about this is that with
the anti-monitor being punched through
the universe again it's kind of a view
of some of the different universes that
exist out there Earth 3 for example
which is one of the more popular
universes and in fact DC has recently
done a series of stories that expand the
Earth 3 Universe thank God it only took
him like 60 years to do but the thing
about this is that again as you have the
anti-monitor just kind of crashing
through these realities Barry keeps
delivering the infinite Mass punch over
and over and over again and in fact two
universes that they end up passing
through are Earth 66 and Earth 789 now
the funny thing about this is that as
far as I'm aware I don't think we've
seen Earth 789 and I think that's a new
introduction to the Multiverse I'm not
going to swear to it my knowledge on
DC's Multiverse isn't anywhere near as
expansive as it is about Marvel's
Multiverse Earth 66 that exists in a
line of comics that DC has been
releasing for quite some time called
Batman 66 that's basically the Adam West
Universe right the Adam West Batman
Universe right so like Cesar Romero's
Joker and that kind of thing it's cool
right it was fun but Earth 789 looks
like it's basically the home of Batman
89 right like the original Batman story
that had like Jack Nicholson's Joker and
like Michael Keaton's Batman it's cool
right I mean I don't know that they've
released a comic line based on that I
think it's just relying and referencing
the movie from back in back in 1989 it's
still a cool concept and I love the idea
but again once the anti-monitor regains
his bearings then like The Jig Is up
right like it's just one of those things
where like it's all this just the
anti-monitor overpowering Barry Allen
and the reality is this could only go on
for so long and again he's just knocking
him through whole other realities
through whole other universes but in the
midst of all this with Wally West having
been freed in the time when Barry Allen
was just constantly pummeling the
anti-monitor with the infinite Mass
punch Wally West ended up traveling
across the Multiverse and grabbing all
these different people from across the
Multiverse so you basically got Green
Lantern Batman that version of Superboy
that you see with crypto that's from the
old Super Friends show which is cool to
see man like it's awesome but it's going
to be one of these interesting things
because it's literally a newly assembled
Justice League team facing off against
the anti-monitor led by Wally West now
despite the fact that this is a very
capable team and even Barry says that
because the nature of superheroes seem
to be in intrinsic to the Multiverse
these guys immediately know how to fight
as a team now a lot of this also seems
to be due to the fact that they come
from different worlds where they have
their own different version of the
Justice League and while these different
characters all look different to the
other person's eyes at the end of the
day Wonder Woman is still Wonder Woman
she's just a different version of her
character which might have like a
different attitude or something along
those lines but it's like you're
basically the person I spend all my time
fighting with you just look different
and so they're able to work in unison
because they're just a team but despite
how capable they are and despite how
they're able to unify at the end of the
day it doesn't make any difference
they're all seemingly overpowered by the
anti-monitor and the truth about this
and Barry Allen Nails it when he says
the anti-monitor is a level of power
that none of them have ever faced off
against now this is where things get a
little murky with the nature of the
anti-monitor we're leaving out
everything with perpetua right we're
ignoring all of that stuff largely
because DC seems to be doing the same
thing when the anti-monitor originally
appeared in crisis on infinite Earth it
was a hoss right the anti-monitor was
was I mean it was like all fell before
the power of this guy I mean this dude
was wiping out whole universes with a
wave of his hand it was nuts how capable
he was I mean he like literally he
destroyed the Specter like it was crazy
how powerful this guy was but the thing
about this is that in future appearances
when you go into like Jeff John Sinestro
core War as part of the Green Lantern
and so on and so forth the anti-monitor
returning he seemed to have been reduced
in power as great of a story as Sinestro
core was it didn't seem to be an
accurate depiction of the anti-monitor
regarding his power because the reality
is the anti-monitor doesn't need a
Yellow Lantern ring he doesn't need to
channel like the the emotional and the
emotional entity of fear he doesn't need
Parallax right like he's just Way Beyond
that level of power so it's just one of
those interesting things that DC's done
with his characters in terms of like how
they shifted him and so on and so forth
what DC is doing here is they're showing
the anti-monitor with a with really his
original level of power where it takes a
unified verse version of superheroes to
really just hold him off as best they
can they can't even defeat the guy but
in an effort to defeat him what they end
up doing is using the kind of magical
variations of themselves they actually
end up opening a portal to the
antimatter universe and they do the only
thing they can do which is Barry Allen
basically using the infinite Mass punch
to knock the anti-monitor back into the
antimatter Universe once that's done the
the portal sealed and that's it the
entire basis behind this story was to
basically bring back the anti-monitor
and then set it back to right the
anti-monitor is supposed to be in the
antimatter Universe it's DC basically
putting him there and then kind of
restoring him to his original role and
restoring the Multiverse of DC Comics to
its original Multiverse right and
basically saying like this is where the
anti-monitor is from and he will stay
there until such a time as we write a
story where we basically bring him back
and that's effectively it but it is cool
to see like Barry Allen almost gets
pulled into the antimatter Universe in
which case he would likely be destroyed
during that transition because its
positive matter meaning antimatter he
basically to be broken down and
annihilated but of course he's
ultimately saved by Green Lantern Batman
and brought back and so the different
members of these Justice Leagues end up
going back to their own individual
realities and the days save but
following this this goes directly into
the events of like the dark Chrysler
infinite or story but this story I think
is going to be exceedingly important
because it establishes DC's original
multiverses back and what they're doing
is they're basically combining the
original Multiverse with the Multiverse
as it exists now taking the elements
they like and keeping them getting rid
of the elements that they don't like and
that's it right it's kind of like a DC
rebirth 2.0 if we want to call it that
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end thank
you all for watching and I will catch
you all later
Bruce